je défends le brushing
alors tanguy david quand quand ce jeune
homme vous dit pourquoi tu fais ça c'est
quoi pourquoi tu fais ça pourquoi tout
soutien à zemmour 5 comment donc comment
ça s'est passé vous êtes sur l'écran des
idées ouais c'est ça je viendrai j'étais
seul ce moment là je sortais d'une
soirée d'une autre soirée d'accord voilà
j'allais boire un verre enfin un dernier
verre voilà un truc comme ça et si vous
voulez jeter dans un café donc sur les
champs et le gérant me dit je crois
qu'il ya du monde qui vous attend devant
et c'est alors je vois bien aussi qu'ils
avaient une bande aussi lac était devant
enfin voilà qui m'attendait etc qui
réclamaient que je sorte donc j'ai
patienté pendant 20 minutes derrière le
café le temps d'appeler mon humeur nokia
arrive assez rapidement mais il était au
courant je l'avais été les juges avaient
téléphoné pour lui dire lui arriver
rapidement faudrait qu'on se raconte un
constat est aussitôt parce que il ya des
gens qui nous attendons donc voilà
revenu quand même comment il venu quand
elle est venue quand même il était à
côté donc voilà je sors aussitôt
j'entends les fils de [ __ ] il a chopé le
etc enfin voilà des termes très bon
voilà je monte dans la voiture et puis
c'est alors qu'une bande de sauvages
saute sur la voiture tape dessus etc
crache dessus enfin tout ce que vous
voulez et jusqu'au moment où ils
finissent par ouvrir la portière de
force et me sera me donne des coups de
poing des coups de pied ce que vous
voulez me crachent ça a été frappée
ottignies les crachins vous avez des
craintes chez soi et bah oui et me voilà
me crachent à la figure et c'était en me
disant pourquoi tu fais le negro quelque
dieu est là on parle de bounty c'est
parce que aussi
d'ailleurs ouais ouais et aussi voilà
pourquoi que dieu te guident vers
l'islam aussi voilà enfin des trucs un
peu
bizarre voilà il y en a qui monte a
carrément sur le sur le toit de la
voiture enfin qui était couché dessus
comme ça et qui hurle et adopté deux
maires de fils de [ __ ] tout ça et c'est
enfin bon j'ai jamais vu une semaine
pareille dans les yeux de quelqu'un tu
es apprend enfin que vous faites
agresser aussi violemment oui c'est une
première physiquement comme ça c'est une
première verbalement c'est déjà arrivé
et il vous avait parlé un petit peu
avant pas du tout ils ont
dit non quand je suis arrivé dans le
café vous en dit quoi ils m'ont dit mais
pourquoi tu fais ça la france c'est pas
pour nous tant guy déconne pas
franchement voilà qu'au début c'était
plutôt sympa plutôt sympa ouais enfin la
france est bon pour nous non et voilà
c'est pas pour nous pourquoi de soutien
sera six ans et c'est à dire mais c'est
à dire qu'il voulait discuter avec vous
venez pas ouais vous avez discuté avec
eux ou pas du tout est vite fait ouais
et alors je leur ai dit quoi il a
répondu je leur avais répondu qu'ils
réexaminent n'était pas raciste mais
surtout j'étais pas là pour ça quoi
d'accord voilà je t'ai pas là pour
discuter de ces gens là donc surtout je
vais bien qu'il se foutait un peu de moi
ce qui commençait à me déplaire donc je
suis parti dans le café puis c'est là
que s'est passé ce que vous savez
d'accord oui malgré vous nous aviez dit
sur ce plateau que vous aviez une
protection vous n'avez plus de
protection alors je n'ai pas de
protection policière à proprement parler
une mesure de protection qui mise en
place si vous voulez qui fait que par
exemple si j'appelle la police alors que
je suis chez moi voilà il s'avoue jamais
ils savent que c'est moi je suis sur un
fichier de personnes protégées mais j'ai
pas de protection policière proprement
parler vous avez peur maintenant de
renom à soutenir non produites vous
compte rires non pas du tout non au
contraire j'ai même le soutenir encore
plus non non pas du tout non non
moi je sais pas une bande de sauvages et
de racailles qui va m'effrayer voilà
d'accord voilà ils sont contents ils ont
fait les malins on s'entend sur une
voiture mais en faisant peur aussi aux
chauffeurs etc c'est vrai que c'est bien
c'est très intelligent voilà mais c'est
pas pour autant que je vais arrêter de
soutenir zemmour bien au contraire